D
IT'S GOING TO USE JUST ABOUT ANY
POSSIBLE EXCUSE AGAIN FINE TO
CHANGE THE SUBJECT AND THEN
SILENCE ITS CRITICS.
NOW LET'S WALK PAST DOWN MEMORY
LANE.
FIRST LEAVES THE RIOTS
OF JANUARY 6TH AS A
JUSTIFICATION THAT FENDS OFF
CAPITAL WITH RAZOR WIRE.
THEY DID THIS FOR SEVERAL MONTHS
COSTING US TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
I DON'T EVEN THINK WE KNOW THE
FINAL AMOUNT.
IF I TREATED ORDINARY CITIZENS
WHO WEREN'T PART OF ANY VIOLENCE
AT ALL AS INSURRECTIONIST.
SECOND, THEY USED COVID TO
ILLINOIS MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
WHO ARE ACTUALLY TREATING COVID
PATIENTS ALSO SAW RIGHT THROUGH
TONY FAUCI'S BUREAUCRATIC
BLATHER IN THE CDC'S CHERRY
PICKED DATA.
OUR MEDICINE CABINET NEW FOR TWO
YEARS THAT LOCKDOWNS WERE JUST
GOING TO PROLONG THE PANDEMIC
AND CLOSING THE SCHOOL'S WHICH
IS GOING TO END UP DESTROYING
KID'S LIVES.
DOCTORS WHO QUESTION BIDEN AND
ALL OF THESE MEDICAL EXPERTS
THAT WERE TOUTED ON TELEVISION
EVERY DAY FROM THE LEFT, WELL,
THE DOCTORS WHO ACTUALLY KNEW
WHAT THEY WERE DOING AND THEIR
LIVELIHOODS THREATENED.
IN THE END, WE WERE RIGHT.
IN THE MANDATES ARE FINALLY
BEING LIFTED.
OBVIOUSLY NEITHER OF THIS TOPIC
WORK TO TURN AMERICANS AWAY FROM
BIDEN IS MOUNTING PROBLEMS OF
CRIME, INFLATION, ENERGY CRISIS,
AND AN OPEN BORDER.
AND WHILE THE BOB'S A BIT UNLIKE
OPPOSITION IS BUILDING
A REMEMBER VIRGINIA PARENTS.
THEY ELECTED GLENN YOUNGKIN
AFTER SEEING THAT THE TEACHERS
UNIONS WERE REALLY THE ONES IN
CHARGE AND EDUCATION AND IN THAT
WORLD, ARISTOTLE LOSES OUT TO --
AND GEORGE WASHINGTON IS NOT AS
IMPORTANT AS GEORGE FLOYD.
THIS IS GOING TO FLATTEN THE
DEMOCRATS THIS FALL AND I THINK
THEY KNOW IT.
SO THIS LEAVES DEMOCRATS WITH NO
OTHER CHOICE THIS ELECTION
SEASON BUT TO GO WITH THE GOLDEN
OLDIE.
FORGET ABOUT THE GAS POSING IN
ON $5 PER GALLON BECAUSE RUSSIA
IS ON THE MOVE.
>> WE ARE UNITED IN OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE URGENCY
IS SERIOUS OF THE THREAT RUSSIA
IS MAKING TO GLOBAL PEACE AND
STABILITY.
>> THIS IS THE GREATEST THREAT
TO STABILITY IN EUROPE SINCE
WORLD WAR II.
UKRAINE IS IN DANGER.
PRESIDENT PUTIN IS BLATANTLY AND
VIOLENTLY MAKING THE LAWS.
>> LISTEN, GUYS, WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL FOR WAR IN
EUROPE.
LET'S REALLY TAKE A MOMENT TO
UNDERSTAND THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
>> Laura: DO ANY OF THESE
PEOPLE REALLY CARE ABOUT UKRAINE
AND RUSSIA?
NOT LONG AGO, OBAMA TALKED ABOUT
HE WANTED TO MAKE DEALS WITH
RUSSIA AND THEN HE MADE FUN OF
ROMNEY FOR SOUNDING THE ALARM ON
PUTIN.
>> A FEW MONTH AGO WHEN YOUR
ASKED ASKED WHAT IS THE BIGGEST
GEOPOLITICAL THREAT FACING
AMERICA, YOU SAID RUSSIA.
NOT AL QAEDA, YOU SAID RUSSIA.
IN THE 1980s ARE NOW CALLING
TO ASK FOR THEIR FOREIGN POLICY
BACK BECAUSE THE COLD WAR HAS
BEEN OVER FOR 20 YEARS.
>> Laura: THE DEMOCRATS DON'T
CARE ABOUT RUSSIA.
THEY NEVER HAVE.
THEY CARE ABOUT HOLDING ON TO
POWER AT ALL COSTS.
THEY CERTAINLY DIDN'T CARE ABOUT
RUSSIA WHEN THE SOVIET UNION WAS
ACTUALLY A REAL THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES IN THE 1980s.
NOW THE RUSSIA HAS AN ECONOMY
ABOUT THE SIZE OF ITALY'S, THEY
CARE?
BUT HOW DO WE GET HERE?
THE ANSWER, BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
LIES OVER IN CHINA WHICH IS NOW
BECOMES RUSSIA'S BIGGEST BOOSTER
IN THIS CURRENT CONFLICT.
FOR TWO DECADES, AT LEAST HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES, THOUGHT IT
WAS A GOOD IDEA TO BUILD UP
CHINA, MAKE THEM RICHER AND MORE
POWERFUL EVEN.
BIDEN NOT ONLY THOUGHT IT BUT HE
SAID IT.
>> ARISING CHINA IS A POSITIVE,
POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT.
NOT ONLY FOR CHINA BUT FOR
AMERICA AND THE WORLD RICH
LARGE.
>> Laura: I KNOW CHINA HAS ALL
IT NEEDS TO PROP UP RUSSIA NO
MATTER WHAT PUTIN DOES IN
UKRAINE.
BIDEN NOT ONLY GOT A RISING
CHINA, THEY ARE POISED TO
SURPASS THE UNITED STATES
ECONOMICALLY AND ARTIE HAVE A
LARGER STANDING ARMY THAN WE DO.
BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT RUSSIA IS
ANY REAL THREAT TODAY, IT IS
ONLY BECAUSE CHINA IS STANDING
BESIDE THEM.
BIDEN PROMISED HE WAS GOING TO
RETURN US, DIDN'T HE COME INTO
OUR PROPER STANDING IN THE
GLOBAL COMMUNITY, THE
RULES-BASED INTERNATIONAL ORDER
AND THAT HE WAS GOING TO BE A
UNIFYING FORCE AROUND THE WORLD.
REMEMBER THAT?
BUT AFTER ONE YEAR, HE HAS
WEAKENED AMERICA AND HE HAS
UNITED OUR ENEMIES.
QUITE AN ACCOMPLISHMENT.
MARK MY WORDS.
AS LONG AS CHINA IS PERCEIVED AS
THE MOST POWERFUL COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD, THE U.S. IS GOING TO HAVE
A TOUGH TIME CONTAINING SOMEONE
LIKE PUTIN.
RATHER THAN FIGURING OUT WAYS TO
MAKE CHINA WEAKER AND TO UNITE
AMERICA, BIDEN AND THE HILL
DEMOCRATS ARE LOOKING FOR NEW
VILLAINS HERE AT HOME.
SEARCHING FOR A STRATEGY TO
AVOID A 2020 MIDTERM DISASTER,
ADVISORS TO PRESIDENT BIDEN HAVE
DISCUSSED ELEVATING A UNIFIED
REPUBLICAN FOIL NOT NAMED
DONALD TRUMP.
THOSE FROM AXIOS TODAY.
THAT POLITICAL STAGE FROM THE
ISLANDS, MAZIE HIRONO, TOLD
AXIAL I WAS DOMINIC WISH WE
COULD FIND ONE FACE WE COULD
POINT TO AS WITH DONALD TRUMP.
MAYBE A COMPOSITE.
I WOULD LIKE US TO DO MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE JOB OF DRAWING
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS.
WHEN I BEING A MIKE IDEA BEING
CONSIDERED IS TO SUBSTITUTE
TRUMP WITH FOX NEWS.
>> THESE RIGHT WING PUNDITS AND
THE G.O.P. THAT SUPPORTS THEM
REALLY FRANKLY HAVE BLOOD ON
THEIR HANDS.
>> WHAT DOES THIS SAY THAT YOU
HAVE PEOPLE LIKE TUCKER CARLSON
AND FOX NEWS DRUMMING UP SUPPORT
FOR PUTIN?
>> IT IS NOT FRUSTRATING, IT IS
SICKENING.
IT IS UN-AMERICAN.
>> TUCKER CARLSON IS ONE OF THE
MOST DANGEROUS PEOPLE ALIVE
RIGHT NOW, ACTUALLY.
THE VOICES OF THE NEWLY
RADICALIZED G.O.P., THEY ARE ALL
ON THE PUTIN TRAIN.
>> Laura: THEY ARE ON THE
PUTIN TRAIN.
AND I ONCE MUCH RESPECTED
PROFESSOR TWEETED AND DELETED
THIS.
LED BY FOX NEWS CHANNEL
TUCKER CARLSON, THE G.O.P.
TRAMPLING APPEARS TO BE THROWING
ITS WEIGHT BEHIND PUTIN.
IF PUTIN OPTS TO WAGE WAR ON OUR
ALLY, UKRAINE, SUCH AID AND
COMFORT TO AN ENEMY WOULD APPEAR
TO BECOME TREASON AS DEFINED BY
ARTICLE THREE OF THE
U.S. CONSTITUTION.
BY THE WAY, HE ACTUALLY I THINK
WROTE A CONSTITUTIONAL LAW
SCHOOL BOOK.
HE IS IN HER LAW SCHOOL'S RIGHT
NOW.
BUT THIS ISN'T ABOUT SILENCING
CRITICS, IS IT?
NO.
CALLING THEM TRAITORS ARE
QUESTIONING WHETHER INCHING
TOWARD WAR WITH RUSSIA IS THE
RIGHT CHOICE.
PERHAPS HE SPENT TOO MUCH TIME
IN CAMBRIDGE, BUT THE ENTIRE
POPULACE CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT
WAS BASED IN THE IDEA OF MAKING
AMERICA SO STRONG ECONOMICALLY
THAT IT WOULD BE ABLE TO AVOID
FUTURE WARS OR CONFLICTS.
BUT NOW THEY HAVE A MUMBLING
IMBECILE IN THE WHITE HOUSE
BUMBLING US TOWARD CONFLICT AND
THEY TURN AROUND AND TRY TO
BLAME US FOR THEM?
NICE TRY.
OUR NATION, OF COURSE, REMAINS
EXCEPTIONAL.
BUT WE HAVE BEEN DEBILITATED BY
TWO WARS THAT WE DID NOT WIN
BACK AND NOW WE ARE SITTING ON
$30 TRILLION OF DEBT REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS BOTH RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT.
BUT AS LONG AS THE U.S. STAYS
WEAK ECONOMICALLY, THE WORLD
WOULD BECOME A HARSHER AND FAR
MORE CRUEL PLACE.
THAT IS NEWS TO THE LEFT WHICH
HAS BEEN THE LAST 16 YEARS
ATTACKING OUR MIDDLE CLASS.
RATHER THAN TRYING TO FIX BIG
PROBLEMS AND MAKE AMERICA
BETTER, THEY JUST USE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DEMONIZE THEIR
POLITICAL ADVERSARIES.
THINK ABOUT THE STUPIDITY OF
THIS.
WE ARE ON THE VERGE OF WAR.
AND WE STILL HAVE THE SAME
MILITARY LEADERSHIP IN PLACE WHO
COULDN'T GET US OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN THE RIGHT WAY.
THAT IS BRILLIANT.
AND WE ARE ON THE VERGE OF WAR
AND OUR TRADE POLICIES ARE STILL
MAKING CHINA, RUSSIA'S NEW
STRONG FRIEND, RICHER BY THE
DAY.
BIDEN HAS DRIVEN OUR ENERGY
CRISIS HIGHER BY LIMITING
DOMESTIC DRILLING, AND WHO
BENEFITS FROM THAT?
NOT US.
BEFORE DOES.
EVERY TIME OIL PRICES GO UP AND
BIDEN'S SUPPORTERS LOVE HIGH
ENERGY COSTS, THEY ARE CLIMATE
CRAZY, RUSSIA HAS MORE MONEY IN
POCKET TO FUND ITS MILITARY
AMBITION.
PUTIN IS HAPPY.
YESTERDAY, IT WAS TRUMP, THE
BILL AND THEY COULD RUN AGAINST.
THEN IT WAS JANUARY 6TH, THEN
WAS COVID, THAN THE PARENTS
PROTESTING AT SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS, AND NOW IT IS RUSSIA
AND FOX NEWS.
BUT THE IMPORTANT THING TO
REMEMBER IN ALL OF THIS IS THAT
AFTER 25 YEARS OF ESTABLISHMENT
LEADERSHIP, EXCEPT FOR THE FOUR
YEARS OF DONALD TRUMP WHO GOT A
RIGHT, AMERICA IS DRAMATICALLY
WEAKER.
SO GOING FORWARD, IT IS THE JOB
OF OUR LEADERS TO FIX AMERICA,
REBUILD THE MILITARY CULTURE,
AND FIND A WAY TO GIVE MORE
LEVERAGE OVER CHINA.
MEANWHILE, T